You know,
when I started doing this about 10 years
ago in London and when I first started
this job,
I used to literally make lists of people
on Wall Street that I wanted to try to
meet,
um,
every given month.
So I would sit and make a list of 30
people and I would cold call literally
and um,
introduce myself as a reporter who
planned to be on the beat for a very
long time and thought it was important
that we get to know each other in some
way.
And
I think hopefully over the years people
have
taken those calls and occasionally those
meetings and a trust level has
developed.
And I think that's probably true of any
a reporter.
It's really about a
hard work shoe,
leather reporting,
getting on the telephone,
running around to,
in my case is to meetings or events to
see different people and a whispering in
their ear and hopefully they're gonna
whisper back,
uh,
and,
and tell you the information,
you know,
as a child,
I always enjoyed,
uh,
my parents used to have these little
cocktail parties and I always loved
trying to get the adults to tell me
things they weren't supposed to say.
And in many ways that's what my job is
today.
It's getting people to tell me things
that they probably are otherwise not
supposed to say.
And I think you do that by developing
some semblance of trust that you're,
that you're going to be fair and,
and,
and that,
that you get it.
I think that's part of it.
I've tried to study the industry.
I've spent enormous amounts of time.
I can unfortunately do a model,
a dcf model with the best of them.
I wouldn't say I enjoy it,
but,
and I also think that when you studied
it up,
when you,
when you come to the table with the
right questions,
when it's clear to the other side of
the,
to the interviewee,
that you know what you're talking about,
you can get a lot more.
The hardest part for financial
journalists going forward is actually
going to be to get a straight take.
Um,
it's very hard to truly get close to the
action anymore.
I think there was a sense in the
eighties and maybe even part of the
nineties and earlier when you could
really get the CEO on the phone any day
you could,
you could really get inside the story.
But today most of these companies are
pretty lawyered up.
They have a PR apparatus.
It's very hard in real time to actually
get a story that hasn't come prespen.
And while the government is requiring
more and more disclosures as we've seen,
some of these disclosures are worthless.
And so it makes it,
it makes,
it makes it an enormous challenge to be
able to,
to really be able to spot the problems.
Um,
when,
when I'm aware that they're out to lunch
and my goal is usually to tell you that
they're out to lunch,
I'm like,
I can't promise I've,
I've gotten it right every time.
That's a terrific question because
unfortunately in the world of sort of
Wall Street prognosticators,
they only happened to old to be right
once or twice.
So right now,
Nouriel Roubini for example,
who called the crisis,
seems to be the guy that you'd want to
hear from,
or merit of Whitney who told you that
Citi group was in trouble,
would be somebody you'd want to spend
time to listen to you when in perhaps
quote in an article
what other people would suggest to you
that they were making these arguments
for six or seven or eight years.
And had you been quoting them then you,
most people would have told you they
were absolutely wildly wrong.
So it's actually a complicated issue
because some of these people will look
right and be right for the moment and
then won't be right for a very long
time.
Again,
financial television,
plato,
remarkably large role as the medium with
which people were receiving their
information during this crisis.
This was probably the first televised
financial crisis that existed and some
people have blamed tv for the crisis or
for speeding up the crisis
and there might be some truth to that in
that as journalists who are trying to
reflect what's happening in the market,
it gets reflected back and and this sort
of mirror gets mirrored back and forth
and back and forth,
and there's a personalization to a TV as
a medium is so different than reading a
headline that's saying there's a
problem,
but when you're sitting in your office,
especially when it's about yourself or
about a firm that you're trading within
your hearing and seeing another
individual tell you these folks are in
trouble.
It really can exacerbate the situation.
That's not to say that I think all of
these people were doing reporting
irresponsibly.
There were some reports that were wrong
here and there,
but for the most part I must say even
having finished this book,
I watched a lot of tv tapes during this
period and most of the stuff actually
stood up quite well,
much better than I suspect many people
would want to acknowledge.